I’M GOING, I’LL WEAR THE MASK
FOR THE SAKE OF OTHERS.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
TONIGHT, SO MUCH BREAKING NEWS
WE WILL BE COVERING THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE HOUR TONIGHT.
NOW BOTH OFFICERS ARE CHARGED IN
THE RAYSHARD BROOKS KILLING IN
ATLANTA.
THEY HAVE NOW ALSO SURRENDERED
AND WE HAVE KEY DETAILS
SURROUNDING THE ARREST THAT YOU
DIDN’T HEAR FROM THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY YESTERDAY.
KEEP IN MIND, YOU CAN’T INDICT A
HAM SANDWICH BUT THE HIGH BAR
WILL BE 12 PEOPLE ON A JURY
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT.
A LOT OF DEVELOPMENTS.
BUT FIRST, I WANT IS ALL TO STEP
BACK AS A COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO STEP BACK AND TAKE A
COLLECTIVE DEEP BREATH AND
UNDERSTAND THIS MOMENT AND
REALIZE THIS COUNTRY IS AT A
TIPPING POINT.
IS DANGEROUS.
WE ARE AT A POINT WHERE WE WILL
EITHER GO THE WAY OF LAW AND
ORDER, PEACE, PROSPERITY, ONE
AMERICAN FAMILY IN THE WAY OF
SAFETY ON THE WAY OF SECURITY,
OR WE WILL GO DOWN THE ROAD OF
LIBERAL LAWLESSNESS AND TOTAL
ANARCHY.
BECAUSE THE SWEEPING BROAD AND
IN MANY CASES FALSE
GENERALIZATIONS OF GROUPS OF
PEOPLE, AND LET’S BE HONEST,
OUTRIGHT LIES AT TIMES THAT WE
ARE SEEING OFFICERS AGAINST
THOSE THAT STAND IN THE WAY OF
CHAOS AND EVEN THE SAFETY OF
YOUR FAMILY, THIS NONSTOP RUSH
TO JUDGMENT IS INTENSIFYING ALL
AROUND THE COUNTRY ESPECIALLY IN
BIG CITIES BY THE HOUR.
THIS MADNESS TO DEFUND,
DISMANTLE, DESTROY POLICE
DEPARTMENTS IS NOW A CLEAR AND
PRESENT DANGER TO THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
WE WILL HAVE MORE DETAILS LATER
HAS DAN HETTINGER POINTED OUT IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," THEY
WON’T BE FLEEING BIG CITIES IN
DROVES.
POLICE ACROSS THE COUNTRY NOW
ARE UNDER ATTACK.
IS UNFAIR, IT IS SICK, AND IT IS
TWISTED.
NOT ALL COPS ARE BAD.
99%, AS A MATTER OF FACT, OUR
HEROES.
LOOK AT THE CITY OF ATLANTA WERE
JUST LAST NIGHT IT APPEARS WE
ARE NOW SEEING THE BEGINNING --
IT ACTUALLY HAS A NAME, A LOT OF
POLICE ARE CALLING IN SICK, BLUE
FLU.
LARGE NUMBERS OF OFFICERS
CALLING IN SICK BASICALLY SAYING
YOU KNOW WHAT?
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH FOLLOWING THE
CHARGES IN THE BROOKS CASE, THE
OFFICERS HAVE LOST FAITH IN
THEIR LEADERSHIP, LOST FAITH IN
THEIR ABILITY TO ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO PERFORM THEIR JOBS TO
THE BEST OF THEIR ABILITY.
THIS EVEN ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE
ATLANTA MAYOR DESPITE DEMOCRAT,
EVEN SHE IS ADMITTING MORALE IS
DOWN TENFOLD.
HERE IS A QUESTION, DO YOU BLAME
THEM?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ACROSS THE COUNTRY, MORALE IS
DOWN WITH POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND
I THINK OURS IS DOWN TENFOLD.
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY TOUGH FEW
WEEKS IN ATLANTA.
>> Sean: ACCORDING TO A NEW
REPORT FROM "THE NEW YORK POST"
TONIGHT, NYPD OFFICERS IN
NEW YORK CITY ARE BEING
ENCOURAGED TO STRIKE ON THE
FOURTH OF JULY ALTHOUGH A
DEPARTMENT SPOKESMAN IS DENYING
THAT STRIKE WILL THE CURRENT,
REALLY?
CAN YOU GUARANTEE THAT?
BECAUSE OF THAT HAPPENS, NOT
JUST IN NEW YORK CITY BUT CITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, I PROMISE
YOU THAT WILL NOT END WELL FOR
WE THE PEOPLE.
IS NOW BECOMING UNTENABLE FOR
THE GOOD POLICE OFFICERS TO DO
THEIR JOBS AND DO IT SAFELY WITH
THE SUPPORT OF THE COMMUNITY AND
THOSE POLITICIANS.
IS DISGRACEFUL, UNFAIR, UNJUST,
AND IT IS HAPPENING.
THEY RUSH TO JUDGMENT, BROAD
SWEEPING GENERALIZATIONS, THEY
ARE ALL RACIST AS WE HAVE BEEN
REPORTING, BY THE WAY.
SO MANY MAJOR CITIES THAT WE
TALK ABOUT HAPPEN TO HAVE A
MAJORITY OF MINORITIES ON THE
JOB.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE MAJORITY OF
MINORITY POLICE OFFICERS AND
WHILE I DON’T NECESSARILY
ENDORSE THE IDEA OF THE BLUE FLU
BECAUSE OF WHAT COULD
POTENTIALLY HAPPEN, WE HAVE TO
ASK OURSELVES, PUT YOURSELF IN
THEIR SHOES, HOW WOULD YOU BE
FEELING TODAY?
IN OTHER WORDS, WOULD YOU LIKE
BEING CALLED A RACIST OR THOUGHT
OF AS A RACIST OR AS WE HAVE
SEEN IN NEW YORK, HAVE BUCKETS
OF WATER POURED ON YOUR CAR AND
IT BE ASSAULTED AND NOT HAVE A
MAYOR THAT SUPPORTS YOU AND THEN
HAVE POLITICIANS, FORGETFUL JOE
AND COMRADE de BLASIO, HOW DO
YOU THINK THOSE OFFICERS THAT
AREN’T RACIST THAT PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE FOR US EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND NIGHT, HOW DO YOU
THINK THEY FEEL?
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT LIBERAL
CITIES LIKE WE’VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT ARE SURRENDERING TO FAR
LEFT LAWLESSNESS AND ANARCHY
MAKING IT HARDER AND HARDER, IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE NOW FOR POLICE
OFFICERS TO DO THEIR JOBS.
EARLIER TODAY, THE NEW YORK
POLICE UNION CHIEF PAT LYNCH
TOLD FOX NEWS "YOU ARE SEEING
THESE MESSAGES FROM
NEW YORK CITY POLICE OFFICERS
BECAUSE THEY NOW HAVE REACHED
THE BREAKING POINT.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
THEY ARE COMMUNICATING SOMETHING
VERY LOUDLY TO BE THE PEOPLE.
OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS, WE HAVE
BEEN ATTACKED IN THE STREETS,
DEMONIZED IN THE MEDIA,
DENIGRATED BY PRACTICALLY EVERY
POLITICIAN IN THE CITY AND
STATE.
SOME POLICE OFFICERS AS A RESULT
OF THE VIOLENT RIOTERS, NOT THE
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS, BUT SOME OF
THEM ARE NOT.
A LOT OF THEM ARE NOT.
THE 800 PLUS INJURED, ROCKS,
BRICKS, MOLOTOV COCKTAILS.
BUT WE ARE SEEING PLAYING OUT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WITH THESE
OFFICERS BEING ATTACKED,
RUNOVER, SHOT, TARGETED, IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
AND THEY WILL BEGIN TO LEAVE
THIS PROFESSION IN DROVES AND
FRANKLY, ASK YOURSELF, CAN YOU
BLAME THEM?
800 OFFICERS INJURED.
ROCKS, BRICKS, BOTTLES, MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS.
OTHERS HAVE DIED AND SOME ARE
PARALYZED FROM THE NECK DOWN.
SHOULD DISTURB EVERY GOOD DECENT
AMERICAN THAT BELIEVES IN LAW
AND ORDER.
ASK YOURSELF AGAIN, WHAT DO YOU
THINK YOUR COMMUNITY WHEREVER
YOU HAPPEN TO BE TONIGHT WILL
LOOK LIKE IF THESE FAR LEFT
LEADERS GET THEIR WAY?
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN IN THESE
POLICE OFFICERS SAY WE ARE
RETIRING, THANKS BUT NO THANKS?
AGAIN, I ASKED THE QUESTION, WHO
ARE YOU GOING TO CALL WHEN IT IS
TEN, 11, 12:00 AT NIGHT AND
SOMEBODY IS BREAKING INTO YOUR
HOUSE TO DO HARM TO YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY AND YOUR CHILDREN?
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO HEAVEN
FORBID WHEN VIOLENT STRIKES?
WE ARE AT A POINT NOW WHERE
POLICE ARE GOING TO GO ON STRIKE
STRIKE, AND THEY ARE BEING
BLAMED FOR THESE BAD ACTIONS.
WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE THIS.
WAS UNIVERSAL AGREEMENT IN THE
CASE OF GEORGE FLOYD AND WE
ALWAYS WANT TO BE A MORE PERFECT
UNION.
WE WILL GET BETTER.
THE PRESIDENT LAID OUT REFORMS
TO MAKE US BETTER.
HOW ARE DEPARTMENTS GOING TO
RECRUIT GOOD CANDIDATES?
I USUALLY DON’T PAY A LOT OF
MONEY ESPECIALLY IN THE EARLY
YEARS OF BEING A POLICE OFFICER.
HOW ARE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
SUPPOSED TO FUNCTION IN AN
ENVIRONMENT LIKE THIS?
TO BE VERY CLEAR, ACCOUNTABILITY
IS GOOD.
OF COURSE WE NEED TO EXPOSE
ABUSE OF POWER, CORRUPTION AT
ALL LEVELS.
WE DO IT ON THE SHOW EVERY
NIGHT.
WE DID IT AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF THE DEEP STATE, WITHIN THE
FBI OF ALL PLACES, WITHIN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY OF ALL
PLACES.
NOT THE GOOD 99%.
WHAT IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW WITH
THE DEFUND POLICE MOVEMENTS AND
NO MORE POLICE MOVEMENTS PICKING
UP STEAM.
YOU DON’T NEED A HARVARD DEGREE.
THIS WILL LEAD TO A CRIME WAVE,
THIS WILL LEAD TO AN EXIT IT’S
FROM CITIES LIKE YOU HAVE NEVER
SEEN.
I GO BACK TO THIS PIECE,
EXPLAINING THAT LIBERAL
LAWLESSNESS AND FAILED FAR LEFT
GOVERNMENTS IS SIMPLY MAKING
LIFE TOO STRESSFUL, TOO CHAOTIC,
AND CRIME-RIDDEN TO STILL LIVE
IN PLACES LIKE NEW YORK AND
SAN FRANCISCO AND MINNEAPOLIS
AND MANY OTHER BIG CITIES.
WHAT WILL THESE CITIES DO WHEN
THEIR TAX BASE LIKE CHICAGO FOR
EXAMPLE, THEY MOVED AND STATES
THAT DON’T HAVE INCOME TAXES,
LET’S SEE, FLORIDA, TEXAS,
ARIZONA FOR STATES LIKE CAROLINA
OR TENNESSEE, NO OR LOWER TAXES.
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA,
NEW YORK.
THEY HAVE A MAGS AS IT MASS EXIT
ON ALREADY.
JUST LOOK AT THE POOL HALL
COSTS, LET’S SAY YOU WANT TO
MOVE FROM CALIFORNIA TO TEXAS.
OKAY, GUESS WHAT?
YOU’RE GOING TO PAY A LOT LESS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, IT’S ABOUT
$2500 TO MOVE FROM CALIFORNIA TO
TEXAS BUT ONLY ABOUT 400 TO GO
BACK.
YOU WERE DOING U-HAUL A FAVOR
BECAUSE THEY NEED THOSE TRUCKS
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE RACING OUT OF
CALIFORNIA AND BY THE WAY, THESE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE EVERY DAY FOR
YOU AND YOUR FAMILIES DO THIS
BECAUSE THEY LOVE WHAT THEY DO.
THEY ARE WILLING TO TAKE ON THE
RISKS ALL DAY AND EVERY NIGHT.
MOSTLY 95 PERCENT DO AN AMAZING
JOB, THEY SAVE LIVES AND KEEP US
SAFE.